are seeing new indications that covid is
not over in this country 24 states are
reporting an increase in
hospitalizations and cases have jumped
more than 50 percent nationwide over the
last two weeks now this comes as new
york city raised its coronavirus alert
level last week to medium risk
triggering a recommendation but not a
requirement that people were masked in
public indoor settings dr celine gounder
is an epidemiologist who's
editor-at-large for public health at
kaiser health news and joins us now to
help sort it all out for us good to see
you again dr gallander but this is i
don't know anybody in this room that
hasn't heard of someone who has it now
who may be in the hospital
first second time or getting it again
what is happening we we heard that
there's going to be a summer surge but
it's not summer yet why is this
happening now well a couple factors so
one you have this or several of these
ultra super infectious omicron
sub-variants that are spreading across
the country that got started here in new
york city but are now spreading
elsewhere secondly people are just tired
they're not masking they're not social
distancing they're not doing the things
they did earlier in the pandemic and so
of course the virus doesn't really care
what we think it's going to spread are
the people who are getting it are they
vaccinated are they boosted what is
their their status in most cases there's
some of both the vaccines are excellent
at keeping people out of the hospital
but their donations are up
hospitalizations are up and most of that
is driven by people who are not
vaccinated well speaking of surges
do you expect a fall in winter surge
we do uh and modeling out of the biden
administration would indicate we might
have something like 100 million
infections this fall which is pretty
similar actually to what we saw during
the omicron wave over the holidays yeah
okay so if people are eligible for a
booster should they wait till then to be
better protected and wait till
to get it i wouldn't try to game this
out
i think it's been so hard to predict how
this virus is going to spread how it's
going to mutate i would say if you're
over 50 you are eligible if you're
immunocompromised you are eligible go
ahead and get that fourth dose and what
if you're under 50 you don't think you
should get it well if you have an
immunocompromising condition if you have
some other underlying medical illness
where your physician thinks you're high
risk
follow your physician's advice it feels
like regardless of the hospitalization
rates or the case counts that the
country is moving toward a situation
where the fewer people are really afraid
of the risk right so there's a lot more
casual other people get it they're like
yeah i got it i'm just i feel great i'm
good i'm fine no tony i now look at my
calendar and say if i'm going to get it
i hope i get it next week and not this
week yeah i mean that's how crazy it is
so i mean that's thanks to the science
to vaccines right to treatments if you
get it and it makes me wonder as people
get less fearful of kovid is that what
living with covet looks like are we
entering that period i think what we're
seeing is similar to what we've seen
with other infectious diseases take hiv
for example where some people
are pretty well protected because of
their behaviors because of their access
to care other people get left behind and
i think what you're going to see is
concentration of risk among certain
populations who are going to be left
behind and that's what it will mean to
live with covid how do you how do you
write policies as a government locally
or nationally when you have those two
distinct groups
well we could decide that we're not
going to leave folks behind that would
mean doing things like expanding health
insurance so everybody has health
insurance one in 10 people in this
country don't have health insurance one
in four adults don't have access to or
don't have a primary care doctor so we
could change things like that so that
some aren't left behind and what do you
stand on testing i've heard people say i
took the home test it was
negative then i took a pcr test and it
was positive
what is right here so the home tests lag
about say two days
from what a pcr test would show so you
might be pcr positive today and it might
take another two days before you show up
rapid test at home positive i think the
key is to have options options that you
can exercise at home that are easy cheap
to do in addition to going into a
facility and getting tested with a pcr
all right dr celine gowner good
information as always thank you very
much